♪ ♪ ♪
- Daniel Greene milite depuis
longtemps pour une réforme
du mode de scrutin.
L'ancien candidat du Parti vert
du Canada pense que le résultat
des élections prouve une fois
de plus qu'il faut changer
le système électoral.
DANIEL GREENE, ancien chef
adjoint du Parti vert du Canada
- Si on regarde la CAQ, 41 %
du vote populaire et0 0 sièges,
ça, ça veut dire qu'ils ont
41 % du vote, mais ils ont
73 % du pouvoir.
- La CAQ et les libéraux ont
bénéficié du système actuel.
La part des sièges qu'ils ont
remportée est plus importante
que leur part des suffrages.
Mais c'est l'inverse pour
les trois autres formations
politiques. C'est comme si
une partie de leurs électeurs,
et la totalité, dans le cas
des conservateurs, avaient perdu
leur vote.
- Et la poubelle électorale,
c'est là où on jette les votes.
Alors, le Parti conservateur :
poubelle; PQ : poubelle;
Québec solidaire : poubelle.
C'est des votes qui sont
100 % non recyclables.
Alors, non seulement,
c'est antidémocratique,
c'est aussi pas très écologique.
Et quand on sent queototre vote
ne compte pas, comment est-ce
qu'on peut croire qu'on est
représenté démocratiquement?
- Si le Québec avait un mode
de scrutin ppoportionnel pur
comme en Israël, la CAQ
serait minoritaire avec
une cinquantaine de sièges
et les quatre partis
d'opposition en auraient
remporténtntre 16 et 19.
JEAN-PIERRE CHARBONNEAU, prés.,
Mouvement démocratie nouvelle
- C'est ça qui s'est passé hier,
c'est-à-dire la démonstration
que ce système-là est brisé,
est tordu, et comme disait
René Lévesque, "démocratiquement
infecte".
- Les citoyens sentent que leur
vote compte de moins en moins.
- François Legault s'était
engagé à réformer le mode
de scrutin, mais il a renié
sa promesse une fois porté
au pouvoir par le système
actuel. Son gouvernement avait
élaboré le projet de loi 39,
qui visait la mise en place
de ce qu'on appelle un "scrutin
porportionnel mixte
à compensation régionale".
Avec ce système, leélélecteurs
auraient deux votes.
- Tu votes pour un candidat,
donc le mode de scrutin actuel,
puis tu choisis aussi le parti
que tu préfères.
- Géographiquement,
le Québec serait redécoupé
en 80 circonscriptions.
S'ajouteraient 45
circonscriptions de compensation
réparties dans 17 régions,
où des députés seraient élus
selon le vote populaire exprimé.
Avec ce modèle, la CAQ aurait
remporté 75 sièges, les libéraux
16, Québec solidaire 1
alors que le Parti québécois
et les conservateurs en auraient
remporté 10. La composition
de l'Assemblée nationale
serait bien différtete.
- Le système mixte proprotionnel
a été créé après la Deuxième
ererre mondiale en Allemagne.
Et ça fonctionne très bien,
en Allemagne. On a des
gouvernements stables,
efficaces.
- Déàà, on voit l'Australie,
la Nouvelle-Zélande, l'Irlande,
ont tous réglé ça. Et nous,
au Québec, au Canada,
on est encore dans le vieux
système quand nos partenaires
du Commonwealth ont changé
leur scrutin.
- Le débat est donc relancé,
mais rien ne changera
si le gouvernement Legault
maintient sa position.
- Ça prend de la volonté
politique, ça prend quelqu'un
qui décide que c'est important,
la démocratie.
- Ça va prendre quelqu'un
qui croit que la démocratie
avec un "D" majuscule est plus
importante que gagner
des sièges.
- Les partis d'opposition
ont fait entendre leur voix.
Reste à voir si les citoyens
emboîteront le pas.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Montréa